you are Mom the dream is a little young
um King seems like he's very Savvy what
have you told him you know I I haven't
really told him anything I just leave my
black lead by example like if I'm
working out they come work out with me I
asked them to go to church with me you
get booked for clubs you get booked for
videos you get booked for appearances
now that you don't walk in with the
famous body are you going to lose money
I've been stopped a lot of this stuff
but I've been stopped my only fans all
the way in December I've been stopped
doing hostings at clubs and I've been
stopped doing certain posts that I
didn't want to do anymore with like
certain products and things like that
Blac Chyna is moving on with her life
with the help of faith and no fear we
have to really dig deep and figure out
like who it is that we are the reality
star now going by her birth name Angela
White sat down with Tamron Hall to
discuss her recent procedures to reverse
enhancements to her backside breasts and
face because can you get sick you can
die I haven't had any crazy
complications since I got it I got it
when I was 19 years old but now I'm
moving here in life so I want this out
of my ass so I can grow people will say
she is so beautiful why did she ever do
this insecurities and honestly what was
kind of in at that moment being in like
the industry you want to have this image
of yourself to look perfect and it's no
such thing as that okay okay let's start
over this vulnerability that we're
seeing and the desire to talk you say
it's faith that you in your words found
God you recently got baptized a lot was
going on in my life honestly like I had
so many negative things that was being
attached to me into my body into my soul
into my mind was Faith a part of your
journey before now no this was my first
time ever being baptized
China who has 10 year old son King Cairo
with rapper Tyga and six-year-old
daughter dream with Rob Kardashian got
her first surgery at just 19 when she
was an exotic dancer at the time she
says she felt inadequate compared to the
other women I'm looking at myself like
okay this is not this is not it so
that's not gonna get this is
not something so I felt the pressures of
you know trying to hurry up and build my
body including lots of ink over the
weekend she had what she calls a demonic
tattoo removed from her hip y'all know
that I had this Baphomet right
it has to come off so will you ever do
any more surgery any more fillers you're
done I'm done with it yeah
okay I had to like come out show out you
know I'm doing good I'm doing good I'm
just feeling blessed right now
[Music]